قطعة من الذرة [موسيقى] أجنبية ، لذا نلتقي
ببيير روبيا الذي يقضي
أشهر الشتاء كمدرب تزلج
وشهوره الصيفية بين ملعب الجولف
ومزرعة الكرم الخاصة به
مع الصيف هنا يرسم على
ملابسها إنه وقت الحصاد على أرض بيير
اليوم  نحن نختار
Merlot
the Merlot هذا الصباح
وبعد ظهر اليوم سنأخذ كورونالا
كونانا هو
عنب نموذجي من الوديان
يحصد العنب على هذه الأرض
ليس لأصحاب القلوب الضعيفة وفريق بيير
لديه سنوات من الممارسة في هذه
ميكنة كروم العنب هنا غير ممكن
بسبب المنحدر كل شيء
يدويا حتى نتمكن من اختيار العنب الجيد
واختيار زبدة العنب
على الرغم من جودة النبيذ السويسري
لا يحظى بالاعتراف الدولي من
جيرانه الأوروبيين فرنسا وإيطاليا
لا يعرفه الناس  نبيذ من سويسرا
لأننا لا نصدر كثيرًا ، فنحن
نصدر 2 في المائة من الإسقاط
، ولهذا السبب لا يعرف الناس النبيذ السويسري
ولكنهم  ty of the three spine is a
it's a it's a ground so to be most popular
in in the wine business business in Europe
with the Harvest Complete it's back to
the Chateau حيث يتم عصر العنب
المخمر والمعبأ في زجاجات
عاش بيير في هذه المنطقة
ولعب الجولف بكامله  الحياة
وشهدت شعبية الرياضة تنمو
بشكل جيد ، لقد نشأت هنا في كاموتانا. بدأت
لعبة الجولف ربما في العاشرة
من عمري مثل صغار
في عائلتي ، كل شخص
يلعب الجولف يأتي الكثير
من سويسرا للعب هنا في المكالمة
لأنهم يعرفون
البطولة والناس من  ربما تكون أوروبا
مرتين حيث يلعب عدد أكبر من الناس لعبة الجولف
قبل أن
يصبح صانع نبيذ من الجيل الثالث ولاعب
غولف مدى الحياة بيير في
وضع فريد لتقييم أوجه التشابه
بين الاثنين
بشكل جيد
، من الصعب جدًا تنمية
جريفز ولعب الجولف.
أعلم أنه ربما يكون الجولف أصعب
[موسيقى]